the trains are coming to a halt and so
is the economy
many businesses are counting the cost
fewer people are visiting and they've
got less to spend
on Saturdays business at this gift shop
is down by half I've just noticed that
the days where the strikes are happening
are my quietest days and obviously over
the last few months has been tube and
bus as well having strikes but the
trains have had the biggest impact it
just means that how can we survive how
can we pay our bills if people do not
come in
even when the trains are running people
are hardly in the mood to spend wages
aren't keeping up with inflation and
workers like Flora have had enough we
are striking as teachers because
teachers are being asked to do more and
more with less and less we tighten our
belts we think very carefully about the
food that we buy
um I have colleagues who do second jobs
and work in a supermarket I have
colleagues who visit food banks the
teachers aren't alone industrial action
is Rife across the public sector a sign
of the economic turmoil we Face the
economy is flagging under the strain of
high inflation and high taxes which is
leaving people with less disposable
income each month no wonder they're
protesting about this decline in their
living standards but strikes like these
are doing damage of their own to the
economy
GDP has still not recovered to its
pre-pandemic size first lockdowns cause
growth to plummet but the country is now
battling other economic shocks including
brexit and the Ukraine war
ministers however are focusing on the
positives these are much better figures
than anyone would possibly have
predicted even three months ago but
there is still much work to do we still
have inflation that is much too high
that's causing a lot of pressure for
families up and down the country that's
why we've got to stick to our plan to
get inflation down to get growth up and
to get the economy Motoring in the way
that we all want
inflation was a major topic of
conversation at a meeting of G7 Finance
ministers in Japan
but despite his optimistic comments few
among them will have been feeling these
economic woes as acutely as Jeremy Hunt
Gareth now on Sky News